when the game gets announced your first
feeling is okay are people going to like
this we can get excited about this
you've got a secret a little bit of a
secret you want to share it with
everybody because everyone can be super
excited comes out the atmosphere in the
office is just incredibly hectic I had a
little bit of anxiety because that's
normal because that's what happens when
you're venting on something everybody
here is excited about this the real
question is are they going to appreciate
it for what it is
[Music]
the things that we think about and get
really anxious about in the continuation
of you know such a big franchise like
Borderlands is always the are we
providing something in the game that
fans are going to react to and want
sometimes I'm a little nervous that
people will look at this and say why
isn't it
Borderlands 3 because we wanted to tell
more stories to take place in the world
that's here and also three more lines
one in Borderlands 2 we're trying to
give them something for for everyone who
still has their conscious and still
wants to play more Borderlands you know
I have no idea because I know we wanted
to do something with the bandit bus that
was always the intent there it was that
they made something this takes place
chronologically at record lines one that
could literally be the blue bus from
Borderlands 1 they just stole it or
however the idea that they somehow got
ahold of that Boston and threw been crap
on top of it is it's pretty good the
idea for the pre-sequel basically came
about where randy pitchford worked
something out with 2k where we wanted to
make another Borderlands game but also
wanted to be able to work with 2k
Australia to make it basically something
that we wouldn't make entirely
internally they finished up Irish rock
infinite and they had some sort of a
what they wanted is know what their next
big adventure was we felt like there was
just a lot more that we could be doing
in the borderlands universe and the idea
of another standalone experience had
come up it really came from a sort of
mutual momentum to the logical place of
what can we do that would be fun and
cool telling cool story and let us work
with these really great guys in
Australia
[Music]
if we continue with that flip and here
it won't be able to aim at you won't be
able to shoot at you and not facing you
yeah yeah because well that that's funny
because that was the original problem
that we were having if we try to turn
him around here would ya
good we got him if he's being explained
only sports 3 that's what I saw a
movement an end hmm so unless Pat Coates
in something specifically for its
support for animation so it looks good
we needed three parts but that's what I
was thinking sookay Estrella was
actually formed as a rational games
Australia way back in 1999 we're
celebrating our 15-year anniversary this
year same as gearbox it's a kind of
funny coincidence we just kind of
wrapped up ten years of development on
Bioshock one two in BioShock Infinite
last year and that's when we came about
working on this game Borderlands the
pre-sequel the way where it generally
works is I think a lot of the design and
a narrow stuff is handled over here we
have lot of really talented art guys
over in dollars who handle all the
direction which we then kind of
implement over here so there's a lot of
different like Studios working on this
and then we have a sort of juggle
between it but it seems to work pretty
well
we found a lot of similarities between
the way we work to the point where our
strengths just come out naturally I
never would have expected that
Australians would get along really well
with Texans
there's just something between our two
Studios we seem to get each other pretty
well it's very important that we reach
our goals every week because at this
point there's nothing that we can say or
where we keep it for later we'll see
that later because I won't be any later
exact time in the project for everybody
needs to give everything it's right now
gearbox is enabling Australia to really
bring their creative vision to it but
Australia is respecting the experience
and everything that your box has done to
to build the brand
I haven't happy to take some credit for
four more lines generally existing
actually really proud of that but it
doesn't exist without gearbox and the
team two people and there's some really
cool stuff that shows up every day you
go pick over someone's shoulder or
wonder in the designer room and see
somebody building something that I never
thought of never imagine it's two great
teams working on this project doing some
really really fun and creative stuff
[Music]
between borderline is one or more lines
- we have this really interesting story
that we've never told there are a couple
of quests in this game that are just
ridiculous in vorlons one the moon is a
solid piece of rock and beurling's -
it's all cracked and damaged there's a
space station up there and handsome jack
is taking charge it's fun building it as
character and getting to see another
side of Jack and understand his story
I'm super stoked bringing the story to
the players
[Music]
the cannon
[Music]